dans ce gîte et raphaël blanc d'amour
journalistes à bruxelles
bonsoir a failli blanc d'amour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rtl france
comment est ce que les belges accueille
ces nouvelles mesures de restriction
ben évidemment avec beaucoup d'amertume
et de résignation ça fait plaisir à
personne de voir de nouveau essayé de
garder distances avec ce que l'on
apprécié mais il ya aussi une forme de
rigueur et les gens essayent de temps
gagne mal de faire respecter la
distanciation social ou même le port du
masque ce qui est relativement bien ses
envies au sensible des nouvelles
infections pourtant en france aussi il
ya une circulation accrue du cornât
virus la belgique est ce que c'est un
exemple à suivre pour la france ou bien
est-ce que celle inverse aux yeux des
belges
c'est difficile à dire et puis c'est
difficile je pense de parler au nom de
tous les belges
ce qui est sûr c'est que on a beaucoup
regardé la gestion de la france au début
de la crise et je pense que le fait que
les autorités belges ont fait le pari
entre guillemets de la transparence
c'est-à-dire en faisant des conférences
de presse quotidiennes pour dire le
nombre de patients qui étaient atteints
hospitalisés et les nombreux
malheureusement de décès je pense que ça
a payé et rassurer en partie la
population après est-ce que la france ou
la belgique qui est un exemple à cieutat
je ne serai pas bien le ministre fédéral
des affaires étrangères philippe goffin
a dit en parlant de la deuxième vague je
cite on l'imaginait est ce que ça veut
dire que la belgique s'attendait à un
regain de l'épidémie
outre ces nouvelles mesures restrictives
parce que on pourrait s'attendre un
nouveau confinement prochainement
alors oui on s'y attendait ça les
épidémiologistes l'avait annoncé
malheureusement clearwire
une deuxième vague alors on savait pas
exactement quand ce que saidal et en
septembre en octobre pour l'instant on a
l'impression que ça commence maintenant
après votre question c'est est pardon la
question était de savoir s'il y avait
possiblement 1re confinement qui était à
l'étude du côté de la belgique et des
autorités belges
pour l'instant c'est pas annoncés tels
quels
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a confiné
socialement c'est à dire qu'on a réduit
la pub avec les personnes avec
lesquelles on a contacts mais pour
l'instant c'est pas à leur 1re
confinement malgré car on verse qui est
la ville où il ya le plus qui concentre
le plus de nouveaux cadres comme est de
des questions se posent sur ce qu'on
doit confiné cette ville en particulier
quelqu'un il ya un couvre-feu à anvers
alors pas aujourd'hui pour des questions
juridiques ça pas été encore mis en
place à devrait être mis en place à
partir de demain donc à couvrir fait
qu'il devrait commencer de 23h jusqu'à 6
heures du matin donc une des craintes en
fait c'est que les bars à la fermeture
des bars les gens continuent à faire la
fête mais juste en changeant de province
deux villes et a il ya un petit peu plus
loin et propagent le virus par la même
occasion il ya également cette mesure
concernant les bulles de contacter un
c'est un terme que vous utilisez chez
vous du côté de la belgique
on passe de 15 à 5 personnes est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus alors en
fait on est passé de la bulle social
c'est là le nombre de personnes avec
lesquelles vous pouvez faire des
activités boire un verre aller au
restaurant et c'est à partir en vacances
et avant c'était 15
on pouvait on avait le droit d'aller
voir 15 personnes par par personne
maintenant une passe de cinq personnes a
par foyer donc ce qu'il vous dira que
désormais si vous voulez aller voir aux
amis et bien vous allez faire le devoir
le faire le choix est limité
dernière question philippe goffin a dit
que la belgique était au coeur de
l'europe aujourd'hui que pensent les
belges de
la réouverture des frontières alors elle
a eu lieu il ya quelques semaines et
pour être allé en reportage aux
frontières franco à la frontière franco
belge
c'était quelque chose qu'on attendait
avec impatience notamment de la part des
commerces mais aussi des familles qui
est parfois se retrouver dans des
situations où l'une était en belgique et
l'autre en france et ne pouvait pas se
voir merci raphaël blanc d'amour d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journalistes à bruxelles